good morning from minneapolis the
president has expressed his relief and
hopes that it will represent a moment
of significant change for america the
jury took just over 10 hours to deliver
what had been
anxiously waited for for weeks late last
night the former police officer derek
chauvin
was found guilty of murdering george
floyd by kneeling on his neck
for more than nine minutes his reaction
in court
unflinching george floyd's family has
said finally
it's a good day to be a floyd
the whole world witnessed what derek
chauvin did to george floyd
all right please be seated
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict but it was a jury
that rendered the ultimate judgment
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
there was almost no reaction from the
former police officer guilty on three
counts
of murder and manslaughter
then like mr floyd handcuffed behind his
back
unlike mr floyd given the dignity of
being treated with respect
the trial examined in harrowing detail
the last moments of mr floyd's life
in may last year the justice that so
many had demanded
welcomed outside court the jubilation
mixed with relief
in a city and a country that have been
on edge
feeling better now nothing is going to
make it all better but at least
now there's some justice within minutes
the floyd family received a phone call
from the president
and vice president
who then addressed the nation to call
for this to be a moment
america embraces change
we are all a part of george floyd's
legacy
and our job now is to honor it and to
honor
him i can't breathe
i can't breathe
those are george floyd's last words
we can't let those words die with him we
have a
chance to begin to change trajectory
in this country it's my hope and prayer
that we live up to the legacy the images
of mr floyd's death are seared into the
consciousness of so many
perhaps most of all those of his family
i would salute him at every every day of
my life i will salute him
because he showed me how to be strong he
showed me how to be respectful
he showed me how to speak my mind
i'mma miss him but now i know he's in
history
what a day to be a floyd man so today is
a pivotal moment
um for america
it's something this country is needed
for a long time now
yes and hopefully today is the start of
that when i say a pivotal moment
we need change in this broken system it
was built to oppress us
it was built against us
it isn't over yet chauvin's sentencing
and the trial of the other officers
there that day
lie ahead minneapolis and america were
waiting for this moment
but as the prosecutor said this was
accountability for one
police officer justice will take the
work of a whole nation
well outside the court thousands cheered
when the verdicts were announced among
them
george floyd's brother and his
girlfriend who expressed their relief
at the conviction but also their grief
sky's sally lockwood is in minneapolis
and has this report as they waited for
the verdict
minneapolis braced
[Applause]
the tents there exploding with emotion
[Applause]
[Music]
people breaking down they did it
justice for george floyd and a ruling
that told black citizens
they matter
[Music]
but no one was more anxious than george
floyd's brother
representing the family in court i can
get sleep now
i paced back and forth before i even
went into the courtroom
and i sat in one spot in the corner the
same spot by the trash can i always said
it and i prayed
and i prayed for like 30 minutes and the
verdict came back
when the jurors came out guilty guilty
and guilty and i just couldn't believe
it
because african-american people we never
get justice we feel like it's just
us
people spilled into the streets drivers
stopping their cars to join the
[Music]
celebrations
george floyd's girlfriend came to see
the history made
from her immense loss i miss floyd so
much you know it's hard to
it's hard to think about how i feel but
i do know that i'm really
hopeful for change right now i feel like
this has just
opened up a door for so many people
to have their cases reopened to have
people get justice for
their last loved one this ruling has
given a community still
hurting some much needed hope today
is another step to justice for all black
people
and colored people around the world
going forward we will hope to see
a change we'll hope to see we'll hope to
see people like us
police and the police and people marched
perhaps feeling that little bit more
protected
this guilty verdict is an important step
towards healing for this community
but it's also a verdict of what society
will and won't accept
it's how change happens
it's a moment owned by a community who
fought for the justice they were owed
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis now
what is notable on the streets of
minneapolis tonight is how quiet it is
at george floyd square as it's now
called the scene of uh his death back in
may of last year there's been a
a peaceful celebration of his life
fireworks dancing
no sign of any protest no sign of any uh
rioting but what people do want to hear
is what exactly is going to happen next
and what will be those steps that
everybody from joe biden down uh have
promised them as a result of
what they saw uh in that verdict and big
questions for the political leaders here
about what they will do well
we'll be asking uh that question to a
number of people throughout the course
of the morning with a range of guests at
half past we'll be speaking to the son
of the civil rights activist martin
luther king along with a member of
george floyd's
legal team jasmine rand and at half past
eight will be joined by george floyd's
childhood friend cyril white so stay
with us for all of that
greg thank you well let's talk right now
to the secretary of state for digital
uh culture media and sport oliver dowden
good to see you this morning look
the impact of mr floyd's death was felt
uh across the world including here in
the uk
what can we take from this verdict
well good morning and i think the the
first thing that we can
take from it is that justice has been
done and i think it is so
important in situations like this
particularly when people feel the
justice system has not served them in
the past
they see in the united states that
justice has
been done certainly in terms of how we
address
wider questions of racial inequality and
racist abuse certainly in my own brief
i'm very focused
on the sort of racist abuse that we see
online which is why i have been engaging
for example recently with football
players to discuss their experiences
and see what we can do particularly
through our forthcoming online hans
legislation
to make sure that we crack down the sort
of vile racist abuse that we see
routinely online that does raise its own
questions doesn't it because i mean
as you rightly say there's there's been
a a lot of reported cases online it has
been
you know made more apparent i guess by
people talking about it more openly but
but it's a wider reflection on society
isn't it that there are still people in
this country who think it is quite all
right to take to what is a public forum
and say these vile things how do we
begin to address that
well i think it's very interesting that
um
those sort of things were routinely
heard
on the terraces and in stadiums
uh even a few years ago i know sadly it
still happens to a degree now but
there is a lot less of it what what we
need to ensure
is the sort of things that people would
feel wouldn't feel comfortable saying on
the street
they don't feel they have a safe space
to do it
online we need to be robust in
addressing this and
i mean i found it extraordinary speaking
to some of our
leading uh black players so first thing
in the morning last thing at night they
turn on their mobile phone and they've
got this abuse coming in it is just not
acceptable we're working with the social
media companies in the short run but in
the
the longer term we're bringing forward
this online homs
legislation to make sure there are
proper duties on
social media companies to stamp out this
sort of thing from happening
and if they fail to act then they will
face very large fines
up to 10 of their global revenue i mean
look yeah i mean you're absolutely right
i don't think anyone would disagree with
you that that
action has to be taken so that your
people cannot post this sort of material
but i wonder what we do you know what
your personal view is and how we tackle
the wider systemic problem if you like
that there are
whether people can post it or not it's
the fact that people are thinking it
which causes a huge amount of concern
well i i can't stop what people think
but i think we should be clear that the
sort of values that you and
i hold in the uh almost all of your
listeners who find this sort of racist
abuse
repugnant we should not uh be allowing a
space for it to
exist online i also think across my
wider responsibilities
as secretary of state for for digital
culture and media
and sport i'm also ensuring that we
create
opportunities for people from from
disadvantaged backgrounds
um of of of all uh ethnic backgrounds
uh to ensure that they have
opportunities for example in the
film industry working on apprenticeships
to make sure that people have the
opportunity to thrive
talking of people from all sorts of
backgrounds it was the
the fans of the grassroots fans
of football who've really had their say
over the last well 12 hours
really i i i went to bed last night and
chelsea had pulled out of the super
league
woke up this morning and it all gone um
i mean this is a real victory for fans
isn't it
yes it is a victory for fans and in fact
the country has been uh
united in condemning these proposals and
the government
has stood firmly behind the footballing
authorities and saying we will do
whatever it takes to stop this proposal
we were willing to take
very very bold measures to stop this
proposal going
ahead and i'm very glad that um the fans
with the backing of the government and
others have had their say but it's very
important that we don't see this as the
end of the process what this is
highlighted more than ever
is the need to look at the wider
governance of football that's why i
announced on monday a fan league review
led by
tracy kraut something i think commands
support from from many people from
all different clubs and across the
political spectrum
to look at how we address football
governance football finance and indeed
the whole fan experience
do you think though that that is uh
going to be enough for
itself to stop these sort of moves from
happening again
well we have been clear as a government
and i was
explicitly clear from sunday night prime
minister and i
met with fans and with football
governing bodies
yesterday morning i met with the
president of uefa
on monday and i'll be speaking to him
again later today we've been
absolutely resolute in saying that we
will not have our national game
taken away from us for profit this is
as much part of our national heritage as
our great stately homes
our galleries our museums our our
theaters
our cathedrals and we as a government
will do whatever it takes to step up to
protect it and i'm very glad that
working
with fans we have given strength to fans
in
in stopping this and i pay tribute to
all of the fans and we saw it last night
with
with chelsea fans they won't put up with
this and i'm glad that clubs have
listened to it
i mean it's nice to see you applauding
the the passion and there is an awful
lot of passion
there but what about the passion of some
of your colleagues and i'm thinking of
of johnny mercer you know someone who
did three tours of afghanistan
hugely passionate about the work he did
passionate about the armed forces
passionate
about the veterans who in effect said he
was forced to resign as veterans
administered last night because
the prime minister is not sticking to
the veterans pledge
that he signed in the run-up to the
general election in 2019
something's got to change hasn't it well
i have a great deal of
respect for johnny i i like him
enormously and i work closely with
him as a minister i don't think johnny
is entirely correct on this first of all
we set up the office of veterans affairs
indeed i worked with him
on that we funded that office and we've
introduced a number of
measures to support veterans through it
in respect of veterans uh
being hounded in those real concerns
that we have pledged to
address in terms of ensuring that
veterans don't face
uh const the constant threat of going
back through the courts for
the past actions forgive me forgive me
for interrupting but i know you
appreciate the type for time because
you want to move on to do something else
and but in terms of of the
the constant hounding i mean what he's
saying is you've brought in
that cover for some people but not for
those people who served in northern
ireland who have already been the
subject of a lot of investigations
we're talking veterans now in their 70s
and 80s who
mr mercer says in some cases drinking
themselves to death because they're
so concerned about what's happening to
them well
as you rightly say in respect of
overseas operations we've got
the bill that will conclude its passage
through the house i believe in the next
couple of days
in relation to northern ireland veterans
we are
currently working through government on
that we're actually
ministers as we speak are are signing
off uh legislation on that which we will
bring forward in the next session
to address precisely that problem i know
from conversations with the prime
minister
that he's absolutely determined to
address this
okay look appreciate your time this
morning minister thank you
thank you uh ali fortescue was listening
to that morning to you i mean look uh in
terms of the football which is
is what falls most under the remit of
the secretary of state this morning
clearly delighted but saying that you
know they're in effect going to try to
stop this happening again it's unclear
as to whether they actually could
yeah i mean i think you're right it's
unclear as to where they actually could
we've
heard about lots of things they were
trying to do potentially to disrupt
um the the clubs from being able to do
this things like policing and i think it
is a difficult line when you're talking
about the state interacting in the free
market in that way
and i think there is a worry that the
way that the premium
the way football is going will we see
something like this
potentially happening again it seems
almost like the natural
progression when we're talking about
clubs that inevitably will want to chase
the money so you rightly were asking him
about that and he made clear that they
are going to
this tracy crouch review that we know is
ongoing is going to continue to look at
this
how clubs are managed but i think there
is a difficult line for the government
to tread him i think there will be a lot
of relief
that ultimately it was fans and the
pressure rather than the government
really having to step in that has led to
the clubs
withdrawing their support for the super
leap okay lovely ali thank you well
despite the departures the super league
said it was convinced the status quo of
european football
does need to change and it was
considering steps to reshape the project
ender brady reports
this was chelsea fans taking their
message straight to the club's doorstep
hundreds of supporters blocked the
entrance to stamford bridge
to highlight their opposition to the
proposed european super league
well chelsea's owner roman abramovich
famously says very little in public but
tonight here his club's fans have
certainly
made their voices heard they have to
listen
if the fans aren't behind it
then i will honestly boycott the matches
no one's going to watch them
it's over for them
within minutes ward came through that
the club had decided to withdraw from
the competition
followed quickly by manchester city i am
happy but we should never join
in the first place they should know what
chelsea's about and they should know the
fans would be up here but fans weren't
consulted clearly the players weren't
consulted
within hours the other four english
clubs had also pulled out
in manchester the issue brought together
fans of both clubs
city and united both against the
proposals
i'm absolutely delighted uh you know
that how events have
unfurled this evening it's a relief
first and foremost
but long term we need to make sure that
this doesn't happen again
and that our club doesn't sign us up for
this again
united's executive vice chairman ed
woodward later resigned from his role
at old trafford and this was the
reaction from former manchester united
defender gary neville
whose opposition to the plans had gone
viral earlier in the week
and these six sets of owners in this
country and obviously the other ones in
europe
have misread this situation badly we're
in the midst of a pandemic we've been
locked in for eight months
we're not in a decent place here and
they've tried to run away with the crown
jewels
whilst we're all down and they basically
made everybody rise
a premier league captain's meeting is
scheduled for later today
but it seems the whistle has blown on
this project before a ball
has even been kicked and the brady sky
news
at stamford bridge
well at quarters at nine i'm going to be
talking to the former fa chief executive
and chief executive of the footballers
associate football supporters
association
and also a former professional
footballer about the very latest
on the european super league let's take
a look at some of the other stories this
morning
and the tony blair has said uk
authorities should publish
more information on the covid
vaccination program to allay concerns
about the astrazeneca jab
the former prime minister warned that
global vaccination efforts
risk being undermined if they're
discredited for reasons
based on what he called unjustified
anxieties
about safety or efficacy and i'm going
to be talking to tony blair about the
vaccination program at a quarter past
nine this morning
china's president xi jinping will attend
a u.s led
climate summit on thursday following an
invitation from
president biden president biden has
invited dozens of world leaders to the
virtual summit
as the united states rejoins the 2015
paris climate agreement
beijing and washington clashed recently
during the first high-level talks
between the two in alaska
last month
jim steinman the grammy award-winning
composer who wrote
bat out of hell for meatloaf has died at
the age of 73.
his brother says he died near his home
in connecticut
his other brother died just a few days
earlier
from kidney failure
experts say regular exercise lowers the
risk of dying from infectious diseases
like covid by more than a third
scientists at glasgow caledonian
university have found two and a half
hours a week of physical activity
that gets you a little bit out of breath
can have a significant
impact on immunity
now the queen is to mark her 95th
birthday
today just days after her husband the
duke of edinburgh
was laid to rest in windsor this will
mark the first birthday in over three
quarters of a century without her
consort
by her side well let's talk to our royal
correspondent
rihanna mills and this is not a birthday
for the queen to celebrate is it but but
simply want to mark i would imagine
well yeah for the first time in 73 years
she will
mark her birthday without prince philip
by her side and while
on the weekend we saw that at the
funeral she was
in many ways a picture of composure i
suspect behind the scenes privately
the last 10 days have been very
difficult for her and for anyone who
loses a loved one often it is those
birthdays and anniversaries
that can be particularly challenging now
we're told that she is going to
mark her birthday in a private low-key
manner we're not anticipating that any
pictures are going to be released
there aren't going to be any military
gun salutes as you would usually expect
and that's because the royal family
are still in mourning but also the point
was made to me that it was never going
to be kind of a big
occasion anyway the focus was always
going to be on
marking prince philip's 100th birthday
which was due to take place
in june instead and of course actually
around her
actual birthday often there aren't big
celebrations because we have that troop
in the color that happens
uh in the summer of course again for a
second year that's had to be called off
because
of covid but they're still working out
the plans about how that's officially
marked
uh in the summer but also of course you
would anticipate that mems of the family
will
arrive at windsor at times today of
course that will be kept
incredibly private but as we heard last
week the family
very much saying that they will continue
to rally around the queen
as prince philip would have expected
them to okay rhiannon thank you
okay time for a check on the weather for
you this morning naz
there you are good to see you this
morning what have you got for us today
um well it's looking fine again for many
areas but we do have a weak cold front
working its way
southwards and what that's doing is
bringing colder air from the north
and cloudy skies across southern areas
with a few sharp showers
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so generally speaking we're
looking at fine conditions for today and
for the rest of the week but
over the next 24 hours or so we've got a
weak cold front working its way
southwards and it is going to bring with
it cooler air from
the north as it sweeps down further
south and in fact it's also bringing
cloudy skies
this morning across many central and
northern parts of england wales and
ireland so
quite a gray start across these areas
for this morning
and a few spits and spots of rain are
likely as well whereas across parts of
the north it's a mainly dry and chilly
start to the day
it's quite frosty particularly cold in
some rural spots of scotland where
temperatures have dropped
below freezing across the south it's a
fairly mild start
mainly dry and bright but there is some
mist and fog across southern and eastern
parts of
england now going into this afternoon
that weak cold front moves its way
further southwards to many
central and southwestern parts of
england and wells bringing cloudier
skies still a bit of brightness but
cloudier skies
a few showers are likely to break out
across southern areas especially so
across the southwest they could be quite
sharp later but as you can see it still
stays quite mild across southern areas
especially in the south
west where locally temperatures could
get to 17 or 18 degrees celsius further
north
temperatures will be lower it's a cooler
day but there's lots of sunshine to be
had across scotland
northern england and northern ireland
and later across central southern areas
welcome back to minneapolis let's get
more now on our top story the former
police officer derek shovin
has been found guilty of the murder of
george floyd
the case sparked global outrage
triggering protests in the us
not seen since the civil rights unrest
of the 1960s and
conversations about the legacy of
colonialism slavery and racist policing
here in in the us and in the uk as well
our u.s correspondent mark stone
has been taking a look at how the case
has changed the united states
and beyond
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george floyd was not the first and he
will not be the last
but he was the first whose final moments
we all saw
nearly 10 minutes of agony filmed and it
triggered something globally
from the streets of the place where he
died
to the steps of the white house
look at america they're killing us
people could see themselves uh in george
floyd they could see a person who looked
like
them more or less uh being uh
maltreated by the police and and i think
that many people felt that that was
unfair
it was quite remarkable
and it stirred something well beyond
america black lives matter was a
movement rekindled
it prompted introspection difficult
conversations about race
power and colonialism
people and their governments were forced
to confront their own history
legacies of white supremacy in so many
parts of the world
we hear stories but that's very
different than seeing stories
so watching the face of the policemen
of derek watching his face
watching someone being killed that was
suddenly communicated across the globe
here you were intimately there and
present
watching this take place and i think
that for a range of reasons
that simply touched ignited perhaps
an issue that otherwise you had excuses
to turn your head to look the other way
the challenges of systemic racism of
racial disparity had been tragically
captured in the death of one man
and across the country the moments
people heard the verdict
guilty mark stone sky news in washington
well derek chauvin's guilty verdict to
spark reaction from civil rights
activists around the world among the
martin luther king
iii who joins us now uh thanks for
joining us
on sky news this morning first of all i
guess how significant a moment do you
believe this is
for the united states
so i think that it certainly is an
extraordinary
significant moment because this has
never
happened where an officer has been
charged
and they have been officers convicted
from time to time
but this is extraordinarily significant
all charges
uh that he was accused of he was
convicted of uh
which means that maybe we can start
anew but they are a long
a long we have a long long way to go
this is
really just uh the beginning in a real
sense
there's so much talk today about the
change that needs to happen what what do
you think would represent
concrete change out of all of the talk
today what do you think
america needs to see as a result of what
happened today
i would hope that the united states
senate would pass the george floyd
policing act
which is again just one step but it's
one significant step because
it disallows policemen to use the
chokehold and
and the other pieces of things in that
legislation
uh i think though we have to overall
take a look at policing in all
communities across our nation
and particularly communities the
policing as it relates to the black
community into the brown community
because there are serious problems
in how policing occurs in the black
community policing is
over there's over policing and
the reaction uh people are not treated
with dignity and respect people are not
treated like they want to be treated
they treat people very very poorly in
many cases
and that has to be addressed uh and that
has to happen
through uh city councils through mayors
through
uh through um you know through uh
the the state and the policing
authorities
uh so this is uh this really is a it's
not a sprint
it's a marathon
what do you think the message is to to
police departments to law enforcement to
the judiciary
uh around america as a result of of what
happened in court
what i hope is that this is was not an
action against
police this was an action against one
individual who
handled a situation um
that became fatal unnecessarily
uh and so it was barbaric it was
inhumane it was insensitive
it was it was final for george floyd
uh so tragically my hope though is the
message that is sent
is that you're going to be held
accountable for what you do
uh there are body cameras now that
police
have to wear so everything is captured
from that perspective as well as their
individuals with smartphones
who are capturing and usually police are
not held accountable
so i think if if we are able to ensure
that yes you're going to be held
accountable
perhaps it may begin a method of
policemen treating people differently
of course your father famously preached
non-violence we've seen
uh peaceful celebration in minneapolis
tonight no sign of
of anything like we saw uh last year
after the death of george floyd by way
of a reaction
what have you made of the reaction
across the country to
to the verdict today i think people
first of all were relieved
um you know just generally relieved i
i had something strange to happen um
in our home when the first uh verdict
that the judge read the first vetted
verdict is guilty um
our doors began one of the doors in our
home just
started rattling it it's it's weird it
was almost like the spirit of my father
and mother were here saying okay we're
moving in the right direction this is
good
um it had not you know shake before then
but i uh but getting back to the nation
i think
uh relief uh people felt really
positive people felt that maybe they can
begin to have
faith in the system again because people
have lost faith black people have lost
faith because the system historically
does not work
for the black and brown uh and
communities of color
we have to look as always at the
political climate in in washington do
you sense that there's a different tone
obviously as a different president now
from from when george floyd died
do you sense that the political climate
is right to see that change happen or is
it just more gridlock like everything
else
well i hope so but i do not know um
i am hopeful but i am not i don't feel
that oh wow this is one incident that is
going to cause congress to automatically
uh just begin to work with each other
and cause
enough votes to support the george floyd
act
there shouldn't even be any questions
about it passing
but unfortunately that is just not the
case
um i haven't heard any of the reactions
of our republican friends uh
we'll we'll have to see
it's it's the early hours where you are
i know it's the early hours here in
minneapolis
what do you think america will wake up
to tomorrow do you think there will be a
confidence
that things will change uh the the
attorney general here said this is
accountability in one case for
for justice to happen it needs to be
everyone in the united states do you
do you sense that will come and america
will confront that moment now
what i sense is that can come i don't
have a sense yet
until we see whether or not there's an
action
after this particular action and
and actually not just an action many
acts have several actions
to address you know systematic
institutional racism
uh in policing to address the fact that
we need police from the community
that they police so they are
stakeholders they have a vested interest
in how the policing takes place
so that you have more citizen review
boards and no
you know written resistance to that so
that you have
you know more psychological evaluations
that are more in depth
because we have to understand who it is
that we are being
who are being hired what kind of police
are being hired
uh so there's a wholesale review that
has to be done
um and i think we're just going to have
to wait to see i i'm
i think this was a good first step but
we got a long long way to go
martin luther king iii there in atlanta
thanks very much for joining us
uh this morning well um we can speak now
to a member of the floyd family's
legal team the civil rights lawyer
jasmine rand joins us and uh we've seen
the reaction from so many of your
colleagues on the
the floyd team first of all what was
your reaction when you
heard that word guilty in the court i
mean my reaction
i was literally shaking and it brought
me back to the moment that i watched the
announcement
in uh george zimmerman's trial for
killing trayvon martin
and we heard that not guilty and i
remember hearing that word
not guilty and feeling such disbelief
and and disappointment in that moment
and nine years later today um i felt
vindicated when i heard guilty guilty
guilty on all three counts and every
time i heard the guilty it was symbolic
of
not just justice for george floyd but
when i heard the word guilty i i heard
trayvon martin when i heard the word
guilty i heard michael brown
when i heard the word guilty i heard
you know tamir rice
you mentioned those those other names
and i guess that reminds us of how much
this is bigger than just the george
floyd
story how confident are you that that
things will change
whatever the promise is coming from from
the politicians as a result of what's
happened in in this trial
well i think it's certainly a step in
the right direction today
was um a victory in in racial justice
but i would say that we have not yet won
the war shortly or
essentially at the same time the guilty
verdict was announced
holding derek chovin accountable for
killing george floyd
a 15 year old girl named mikaya bryant
was killed in columbus ohio
and so we have a long way to go in terms
of achieving
true racial equality in this nation
what do you think the steps are to get
there then what what concrete steps
would you like to see
that can immediately address some of
what you're talking about there
well as mr king just said uh most
importantly is the passage
of you know the george floyd act um to
ensure
more justice and policing specifically
in black and brown
communities but you can't legislate
hearts and minds
and the prosecutor said something so
significant in the closing argument to
me he said
this entire time you've heard the
defense tell you that george floyd's
heart was too big
um and and now you know that derek
chauvin killed george floyd because his
heart was too small
and i think that our hearts being too
small
that's the problem in our nation it is a
you know
societal problem racism um you know
is in our roots here in america the
white house was built
um on slavery and we have a lot of
historical
wrongs and historical injustices to
correct and i think we have a long way
to go to achieving true justice and
equality in our nation
this of course was the trial of one uh
police officer
three others will face trial later in
the year as it stands at the moment what
do you think the message
that the law enforcement around the u.s
will need to take from
from what happened during the course of
this trial and the verdict
i think that this will change the
conduct of law enforcement i think that
law enforcement now see that they are
going to be held accountable
um when they murder uh black and brown
people any person for that
matter in a manner that is unlawful and
so
i think it's extremely important in
terms of holding officers accountable
and i believe that it will make an
impact in correcting officer behavior
jasmine rand um thank you very much uh
for your time on a
historic day certainly for the the floyd
family a peaceful night here in
minneapolis nothing like the protests we
saw back in in may and june a reflection
of what happened
in that verdict much more to come from
minneapolis during the course of the
show now back to you stephen
okay great thank you well let's talk to
labour's shadow business minister lucy
powell
who joins us now it's good to see you
this morning can we reflect on
on the situation in the united states to
begin with because um
president biden says this could be a
moment of significant
change now considering how much reaction
there was to the death of mr floyd here
in the uk
could it be a a point of change for us
as well
well i really hope so i mean like many
others i'm
was very relieved really and pleased
with the the verdict in in this case and
there's some justice there for george
floyd's
family but we we can't take an
isolated verdict as
change itself change will come because
of
institutional change cultural change and
the way that our system works and that
applies
here in the uk just as much as it does
in the us and here i'm afraid in the uk
you know our criminal justice system
isn't fair towards those from black and
ethnic minority backgrounds you only
have to look at the statistics to know
that you are
much more likely to be stopped and
searched you are much more likely
to find yourself facing the harshest
sentences and to be found
guilty of those harshest sentences it's
why we have
more than 50 of those in youth offender
institutes are from black and ethnic
minority backgrounds when they make up
a much smaller fraction of our
population as a whole so you know
these moments are only good moments if
they
are not moments but they bring about
profound and lasting
um change so it's a step in the right
direction that's happened in the us
because i think it's the first time
in a long time that a verdict like this
has been passed
um but it will only mean something if
it's really really followed through
in a in a long-term meaningful way
okay look thank you for that look i i
know those concerns
um from you and the labour party today
about
liberty steel and and the the potential
of insolvency there despite the fact the
owner has said you know he's not going
to
close any of the plants down on his
watch but we know they're under an awful
lot of financial strain
i mean the government seems to be
indicating it would take action
if there was insolvency to to help
protect
the jobs in the factory you're not happy
with that are you
well look first thing i want to say is
that i hope very much hope that the
refinancing plans
uh that liberty steel company owners
have
uh come to fruition because that would
be the most straightforward solution
for for the plant and all the supply
chain as well
but the government's job and and
therefore our job as well
is to think about the eventuality that
that doesn't come to pass
and you know there are some
uncertainties around that and
i really worry about the government's
approach which is really
standing by and almost waiting for that
to happen before
they intervene and what we're calling
for today is that the government take
action before that point
because if the company does become
insolvent
uh the people who pay the heaviest price
for that even if then
the government steps in after that point
and um
puts in the official receiver and takes
over the company for
a while the people who pay the heaviest
price are those in the supply chain and
there's over 3 000 jobs in the supply
chain
and when this happened in the past with
british steel
uh the suppliers lost around 500 million
pounds that they never got back so we
want the government to intervene
early or at least have plans to
intervene early
to save the supply chain as well as
supporting the workers in in liberty
steel
uh too so so intervene early
how i mean to stepping in taking over
providing some sort of rescue package
themselves how would it work
well how it could work i mean as i say
let's first of all hope that the
refinancing
works and and we may be some still weeks
away from from knowing that for sure one
way
or the other so at the point let's say
that the refinancing
um doesn't work the government could
step in at that point
bringing together all the creditors with
the company
and and seeking a voluntary arrangement
for them to
uh to step in and take over at that
point rather than waiting
we have we have quite difficult
corporate insolvency laws in this
country we don't have the so-called
chapter 11
process that they do in america where
there would be a safe place for this
will happen
and protect suppliers customers and
creditors as well
and but we're asking for the government
to consider
stepping in early in that way to protect
the whole system and i think if they did
that if they
said today that they have that option on
the table it would give
suppliers much more confidence now to
carry on
trading and doing business with liberty
which is already
causing some uh effect on the business
as confidence is beginning to sort of
ever way because
suppliers can't be sure that their
invoices would be paid in in the coming
weeks and the government action now
could provide that extra confidence okay
look um
we're talking to tony blair a little bit
later on
in the program he's really pushing today
for for better vaccination for better
messaging on vaccination
i mean particularly in the light of the
concerns around
astrazeneca and he he's said that some
of the concerns around the blood
clotting issues
are unjustified do you agree with that
do you agree that that we need to
focus on the positives of of the
vaccination rather than
the these small level of negatives that
we have seen come through
well i think the vaccination program and
the uptake from the public has been you
know a fantastically positive story for
for this country and uh you know people
are
queuing up and you're ready to get their
appointments as soon as they
are in a qualifying group and i think
that is brilliant
but i would share some of the concerns
that tony blair
and others have there that maybe perhaps
sometimes
we we don't um amplify the positives as
much as we
amplify some of the potential negatives
and
we do need to keep these risks you know
there are risks in everything we're
doing in relation to covid
we do have to keep those risks in
proportion
to to the other um side of the ledger
really in terms of the positives and the
the need for vaccination
the need for us to uh to reopen the
economy and reopen the country
carefully cautiously and slowly and with
that
will come some risks as well so you know
i i
i think the public are getting good at
sort of evaluating those risks for
themselves and
we haven't seen much impact i don't
think in terms of uptake of the
vaccinations or astrazeneca
but it certainly can't help the
situation if it's overly
negative coverage instead of looking at
the positives as well
but it i mean the vaccine uptake is
slowing down as we head towards the
the younger age groups who are less
likely to be seriously affected
by covert and it also i mean really it
circles back to the whole racism issue
doesn't it because we know vaccine
hesitancy amongst i mean black groups
in particular is is still pretty high
what needs to be done to really get that
messaging across that this is
what needs to happen well
you are absolutely right there has been
um
less of an uptake in the vaccination in
some groups particularly those from
black and some ethnic minority
backgrounds and that is a worrying
concern especially as
many of those communities have been most
at risk of the
the most adverse effects of of covid so
i think as the
vaccination programme continues we are
going to need more tailored
messaging a more targeted approach
to those that still haven't taken up the
vaccine who
who do qualify and that will put those
in that group and i will definitely need
i think a different approach when it
comes to the younger age range
for whom they don't really see the risk
of covid to themselves directly in the
same way that maybe some of the
older population uh does so we've got
off to a fantastic start
over 30 million people now had a first
dose and
and 10 million uh have had their second
uh dose but we we're definitely going to
have to up the ante
to get to a point where we've got you
know most of the population vaccinated
by july especially those groups that
have been reluctant so far
lucy powell good to talk to you thank
you thank you thank you
okay let's have a check in on the
weather for you this morning that's
what's in store today
uh well we're seeing a little bit of
everything today a week cold front is
working its way southwards bringing
cloudy skies across many central and
southwestern areas with a few sharp
showers but further north
lots of sunshine but cooler
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so for the rest of this
week it's generally looking fine but we
do have a weak cold front working its
way southwards over the next 24 hours
and behind that cooler air will come
through
so by the weekend temperatures will be
lower but around average for the time of
year
it is uh currently across central
northern parts of england and wales
where it's quite cloudy with a few
uh bits of light rain or drizzle some
mist and fog across the southeast that
makes its way further southwards the
central and southern parts of england
wells this afternoon with some showers
there for scotland northern england
northern ireland republic sunny and
mainly dry